[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
ein spannender nachrichten tag guten
abend an meiner seite ist für den sport
norbert lehmann als jungen antwort von
mir neue maßnahmen sollen die vierte
corona wahl welle brechen
eine allgemeine impfpflicht und weitere
einschränkungen für ungeimpfte das
wollen bund und länder auf den weg
bringen
nato streitet mit russland angesichts
massiver truppenverlegungen an die
grenze zur ukraine waren das
verteidigungsbündnis moskau vor einem
einmarsch und
verwunderung in der fußballwelt der
prestigeträchtige ballendorf geht zum
siebten mal an lionel messi und nicht an
rekordtorjäger lewandowski
[Musik]
wenn es um den schutz von leben und
gesundheit geht dann sind auch
einschneidende freiheitsbeschränkungen
zulässig so lautet grob vereinfacht die
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts heute beim
krisengipfel danach einigten sich bund
und länder dass sie bundesweite
verschärfungen angehen wollen so soll
zeitnah eine allgemeine impfpflicht
kommen auch zahnärzte und apotheker
sollen beim impfen helfen für ungeimpfte
sind kontakt beschränkungen geplant auch
in der eigenen wohnung und sie sollen
nicht mehr in geschäfte des
einzelhandels dürfen christiane hübsche
berichtet
noch kanzlerin merkel und bald kanzler
scholz leiten die besprechungen
gemeinsam aus dem kanzleramt die 16
länderchefs werden zugeschaltet ein
neuer gast ist auch dabei general breuer
soll künftig den krisenstab der ampel
regierung leiten konkrete beschlüsse
aber gibt es nach der vierstündigen
sitzung nicht ganz oben auf der agenda
bleibt das impfen wir wollen uns aus
dieser lage heraus enten und das
bedeutet immerhin dass wir bis
weihnachten ungefähr 30 millionen
menschen impfen sollen und wollen die
telefon schalte läuft noch da kommt die
meldung über die nachrichtenagenturen
scholz spricht sich für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht bis ende februar aus der
bundestag wird darüber abstimmen müssen
sehr schnell aber wollen die
ministerpräsidenten möglichst viele
einschränkungen für geimpfte das kann
man jetzt locker und für ungeimpfte
nennen man kann es aber auch andersrum
ausdrücken ungeimpfte sind diejenigen
die von der infektion sehr sehr stark
bedroht sind und auch schwere
erkrankungen erleiden können große
einigkeit herrscht offenbar darüber
keine vollen stadien mehr zuzulassen wie
noch am letzten wochenende die rückkehr
der geisterspiele vorerst bis
weihnachten
die unions ministerpräsidenten fordern
von der künftigen ampel regierung das
neue infektionsschutzgesetz
nachzuschärfen vor allem in sachsen ist
die geduld zu ende man kann glaube ich
jetzt von jedem und von jeder verlangen
dass sie sich an diese regeln hält und
wer das nicht tut der und jetzt immer
noch geleugnet so wie wir das jetzt bei
einer kundgebung auch der afg gesehen
haben der richtet sich selbst am
donnerstag will sich die
ministerpräsidenten runde erneut treffen
und dann auch echte beschlüsse fassen
vertrauen in berlin welches signal geht
von diesem tag aus also wenn markus
söder in den höchsten tönen olaf scholz
lobt dann weiß man dass die
übereinstimmung ziemlich groß sein muss
möglich gemacht haben das vor allem drei
dinge erstens der enormer handlungsdruck
der pandemischen lage zweitens die
heutigen beschlüsse des
bundesverfassungsgerichts dass selbst
die weit in grundrechte eingreifende
notbremse rechten zwar und drittens des
olaf scholz den politischen ernst der
lage erkannt und offensichtlich gerade
noch die kurve bekommen hat denn vor
allem die fdp hatte mit ihrer konstanten
abwehr von grundrechts einschränkungen
ja dafür gesorgt dass das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz also immerhin die
erste politische maßnahme der ampel von
der dynamik der virus wirklichkeit ja
überrollt wurde jetzt wird zwar das
infektionsschutzgesetz der ampel schon
wieder überarbeitet aber der schaden
wäre für alle größer gewesen wenn scholz
sich heute nicht bewegt hätte und den
spruch der hohen richter nicht für einen
solchen befreiungsschlag genutzt hätte
dankeschön nach berlin theo koll
wir haben gehört zum ersten mal in der
pandemie hat sich das
bundesverfassungsgericht zu den corona
beschränkungen geäußert und klargestellt
die bundesländer im frühjahr 2020 war
mit dem grundgesetz vereinbar sowohl
schulschließungen als auch kontakt und
ausgangssperren waren verhältnismäßig
auch 80 bundestagsabgeordnete der fdp
hatten geklagt saar attacke hat mir
in dieser ländlichen idylle nachts nicht
auf die menschenleere strasse zu dürfen
für anwohner schwer nachvollziehbar die
gefahr dass man zur nachtstunde jemanden
trifft den mann anstecken kann ist viel
geringer als das tas tagsüber der fall
ist diese freiheitsbeschränkung ging zu
weit meint der
fdp-bundestagsabgeordnete stefan thomé
und zieht vor das
bundesverfassungsgericht
doch die richterinnen und richter sehen
das anders entscheiden heute in einer
äußersten gefahrenlage darf der staat
ausgangs und kontakt beschränkungen
verhängen die botschaft ist glasklar in
einer pandemie haben politiker einen
enorm großen entscheidungsspielraum wenn
sie zum schutz des lebens der gesundheit
und auch des gesundheitssystems die
grundrechte ihrer bürgerinnen und bürger
einschränken
das heißt auch politiker können sich
nicht weiter hinter dem grundgesetz
verstecken denn alle maßnahmen die
aktuell diskutiert werden ob
flächendeckende schulschließung oder
laptops oder auch eine allgemeine
impfpflicht alle maßnahmen können
verfassungsrechtlich möglich sein wenn
es die lage erfordert in ihrer
entscheidung bewerten wie richter
erstmals ausführlich die korona politik
auf knapp 200 seiten prüfen sie neben
den ausgangs und kontakt beschränkungen
auch schulschließungen zwar garantiert
das grundgesetz kindern und jugendlichen
einen recht auf bildung aber auch dieses
recht kann zur pandemie bekämpfung
eingeschränkt werden auch die schärfsten
corona maßnahmen sind damit zulässig
heute sind alle klagen gescheitert
bedauert natürlich persönlich und auch
politisch die heutige entscheidung des
bundes was sonst würde ich das
respektieren aber dass das gericht
feststellt zum damaligen zeitpunkt für
dieses jahres hat der gesetzgeber seine
verpflichtung erfüllt sich gründlich zu
informieren
die herausforderung für den es gebe wird
nun seien die entscheidung des
verfassungsgerichts in die aktuelle
corona lage zu übersetzen
zu den crooner zahlen die inzidenz für
ganz deutschland ist leicht gesunken das
rk ii registrierte 45
1753 neue fälle innerhalb von 24 stunden
das sind 427 mehr als vor einer woche
388 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents ist erstmals seit wochen
zurückgegangen und zwar minimal auf
452 zwei
sachsen versucht schon seit einer woche
mit schärferen maßnahmen die hohen
infektionszahlen zu senken dagegen haben
gestern hunderte menschen demonstriert
in mehreren städten wie hier in freiberg
versammelten sich größere gruppen aus
protest auf den straßen erlaubt sind im
freistaat aktuell nur versammlungen von
zehn menschen sachsen hat bundesweit die
höchste instanz mit fast 1200 70
viele eltern wollen ihre kinder so
schnell wie möglich gegen korona impfen
lassen in ausnahmefällen ist es bei den
fünf- bis elfjährigen schon jetzt
möglich ab zwanzigster dezember soll der
impfstoff in der kinder dosierung in
deutschland dann verfügbar sein
allerdings steht die empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission noch aus oliver
deuker hat mir
kinderarztpraxis brunner hat in
göttingen eltern von fünf bis
elfjährigen sind verunsichert und wollen
wissen wann gibt es einen corona
impfstoff für ihre kinder noch prüft die
ständige impfkommission haben ja doch
eine reihe von chronisch erkrankten
kindern die mit ihren familien sollten
nun anderthalb jahren in seiner selbst
auferlegten isolation zum teil sind und
große ängste haben wegen des infektes
und für diese familien freue ich mich
tierisch zwar können fünf bis
elfjährigen absprache mit dem arzt schon
jetzt gegen korona geimpft werden doch
die verantwortung tragen dann die eltern
der bund übernimmt keine haftung so
lange es keine stiko empfehlung gibt als
stiko prüfen wie die krankheitslast
dieser kinder in deutschland ist wir
prüfen welchen einfluss auf die weitere
pandemie haben kann
welches möglich für die kinder durch die
impfung besteht wie notwendig ist die
korona impfung bei fünf bis elfjährigen
der krankheitsverlauf ist bei den
allermeisten kindern eher milde aber die
inzidenz sind bei ihnen bundesweit mit
abstand am höchsten ich bin sehr dafür
auch die kinder zu helfen damit die
einfach herausgenommen werden aus dem
infektionsgeschehen und sie direkt zu
schützen und eben wie gesagt auch
indirekt die erwachsene denn die
virenlast ist bei allen geimpften nach
kurzer zeit deutlich geringer als bei
ungeimpften entscheidend sind die fünf
bis elfjährigen beim bekämpfen der
pandemie aber nicht was bricht die
vierte welle eine rasche und zeitnahe
impfung aller ungeimpften erwachsenen
und die kinder werden uns den hintern
hier nicht spätestens ab 20 12 soll der
impfstoff von bionic für 5 bis 11
jährige zur verfügung stehen
30 millionen impfungen peilen bund und
länder bis jahresende an aber nicht
überall ist genügend impfstoff vorhanden
der mainzer hersteller bei ihren tag
will jetzt wegen der hohen nachfrage
millionen impfdosen früher liefern in
dieser woche gehen damit 5,8 millionen
an den bund doppelt so viel wie
ursprünglich vorgesehen
zur aktuellen corona lage senden wir ein
zdf spezial gleich nach diesen
nachrichten
die bundesagentur für arbeit rechnet
wegen der pandemie mit einem schwierigen
winter am arbeitsmarkt im november
entwickelte sich der allerdings noch
positiv zwei millionen 317.000 menschen
waren ohne arbeit das sind 60.000
weniger als im oktober die quote sinkt
auf 5,1 prozent im vergleich zum vorjahr
sind
382.000 menschen weniger arbeitslos
die nato und russland werfen sich
gegenseitig provokationen vor präsident
putin beklagt nato militärmanöver in
osteuropa und warnt davor rote linien zu
überschreiten
die nato ist in sorge wegen russischer
truppen bewegungen an der grenze zur
ukraine im grenzgebiet sind laut
geheimdiensten einheiten der russischen
armee panzer und schweres gerät
stationiert die ukraine warnt vor einem
angriff es gebe pläne mit möglichen
einfallstoren
115.000 soldaten stünden bereit wie also
reagieren darum ringen die nato
aussenminister in riga florian a
schon der tagungsort ist ein statement
nato fahnen in riga lettland für einen
außenminister treffen das hat es noch
nicht gegeben die allianz sendet eine
botschaft an letters direkten nachbarn
im osten russland auch der deutsche noch
außenminister bei seinem wohl letzten
auftritt im nato kreis es gibt hier
große einigkeit darüber dass die
territoriale souveränität der ukraine
nicht verletzt werden darf und wenn dies
der fall wäre dies ganz erhebliche
politische und wirtschaftliche
konsequenzen für russland es sind wie
hier im frühjahr an die 100.000 soldaten
die der russische präsident putin an der
grenze zur ukraine aufmarschieren lässt
diesmal werden die warnungen vor einem
angriff schärfer die esskultur der
eskalation durch russland würde die usa
sehr beunruhigend jede erneute
aggression würde ernste konsequenzen
auslösen
wir haben schon einmal gezeigt dass wir
politisch und wirtschaftlich reagieren
können nach der russischen annexion der
krim 2014 verstärkt die nato ihre
truppen in osteuropa trainiert wie in
diesen tagen nahe riga den
verteidigungsfall ein einsatz in der
ukraine nicht mitglied der nato aber
scheint ausgeschlossen woran es nichts
mangelt in riga das sind deutliche
warnungen an russland offen bleibt an
diesem ersten tag des
außenministertreffens aber worin genau
die angekündigten konsequenzen bestehen
würden die bereitschaft zu einer
robusten reaktion ist unterschiedlich
ausgeprägt in riga sprechen sie zunächst
über neue sanktionen gegen russland und
es ist der nato-generalsekretär der am
abend die zusage gibt man werde die
ukraine soweit unterstützen dass sie
sich selbst verteidigen könne
in frankfurt am main fiel heute das
weltweit erste urteil wegen
ns-verbrechen an den g 7 die richter
verurteilten ein iraker zu lebenslanger
haft wegen völkermord und verbrechen
gegen die menschlichkeit als anhänger
des sogenannten islamischen staates hier
der eine jesiden und ihre tochter als
sklavinnen zur strafe hatte er das
mädchen bei glühender hitze angekettet
bis es starb susanne santino
es ist ein historisches urteil das das
frankfurter oberlandesgericht gefällt
hat denn metall j muss sich zum ersten
mal ein mann wegen des völkermords an
den juden verantworten der iraker hatte
mit seiner frau eine jesiden und ihre
tochter als sklaven gehalten das gericht
zeigte sich überzeugt dass der
angeklagte das fünfjährige mädchen
stundenlang bei 50 grad hitze angekettet
hatte es verdurstete qualvoll
die taten ihres peinigers seien teil des
völkermord- plan ist es so das gericht
dank des so genannten weltrechtsprinzip
konnte es das verfahren an sich ziehen
obwohl weder täter noch opfer deutsche
staatsangehörige sind und die tat nicht
in deutschland begangen wurde es ist
eine warnung für täter schwerster völker
straftaten dass sie zur verantwortung
gezogen werden können egal wo sie sich
aufhalten
august 2014
je sieben fliehen ps terroristen nur
wenige erreichen die rettende flieger im
nordirak
unermesslich die brutalität der
angreifer
jesidischen männer werden hingerichtet
und in massengräbern verscharrt tausende
jesiden werden versklavt dass der
angeklagte heute auch wegen völkermords
und menschenrechtsverbrechen an ihrem
volk verurteilt wurde ist für jesiden
weltweit ein meilenstein
von historischer bedeutung denn es ist
das erste mal dass der straflosigkeit
gegen die jesiden ein ende gesetzt wird
auf deutschen boden und deswegen freuen
wir uns über dieses urteil der s bahn
wurde heute zu lebenslanger haft
verurteilt seine anwälte haben revision
eingelegt
ganz anderes thema jetzt eine besondere
ehre für eine außergewöhnliche frau
josephine baker hat heute einen platz im
pariser pantheon bekommen damit wurde
zum ersten mal eine schwarze in die
ruhmeshalle der franzosen aufgenommen
ihr grab bleibt zwar in monaco aber der
sack ist symbolisch gefüllt mit je einer
handvoll erde ihrer verschiedenen
wohnorte nach ihrer karriere als revue
tänzerin war josephine baker im zweiten
weltkrieg als französische agentin gegen
die deutschen besatzer im einsatz und
engagierte sich später in der us
bürgerrechtsbewegung
der november verabschiedet sich
winterlich schmuddelig mit schnee und
mit starkem wind die folgen viele
unfälle auf glatten straßen in
baden-württemberg wurden 15 kinder
leicht verletzt als ein schulbus von
einer böe erfasst wurde und eine
böschung hinabstürzte besonders heftig
wütete schneesturm christian in den
höhenlagen sachsens das autofahren auch
hier eine herausforderung
der davis cup findet zum glück in der
halle statt norbert zur stunde spielt
deutschland gegen großbritannien in
houston und es geht um den einzug ins
halbfinale
das hat das deutsche team seit 14 jahren
nicht mehr erreicht aber gleich zum
beginn der dämpfer peter gojowczyk
verliert sein auftaktspiel gegen daniel
evans klar in zwei sätzen
schon als sieben minuten hat peter
gojowczyk in weiß zwei aufschlagspiele
verloren blickt 0 zu 3 zurück mit 226
verliert die deutsche nummer 5 den
ersten satz
im zweiten golfkrieg nur ein
aufschlagspiel durchbringen leistet sich
insgesamt sieben doppelfehler ein
doppelfehler führt dann auch zum 1 zu 6
im zweiten satz sie gilt die niederlage
des 32 jährigen gegen dan evans nach 55
minuten und führt zum 1 0 für die briten
freude bei lionel messi enttäuschung
dagegen bei robert lewandowski der
argentinier bekommt den
prestigeträchtigen ballon d'or und nicht
der letzte sie so so erfolgreiche bayern
stürmer nun endlich wieder einmal zu
robert lewandowski beim ballon d'or den
kürzeren leonel messi gewann die
prestigeträchtige abstimmung des
französischen fachmagazins france
football zum siebten mal auch für
argentinien sieg bei der copa américa
dass die wahl der 170 journalisten nicht
auf den bayern-stürmer viel verwundert
allerdings viele in der fußballwelt auch
jürgen klopp
du kannst den preis immer lionel messi
geben aber wenn du in dieses mal nicht
robert lewandowski gibt wird es für ihn
schwierig ihn überhaupt zu bekommen der
favorisierte pole bekam die neu
geschaffene auszeichnung als torjäger
des jahres aber das war eher ein
trostpreis
und dann hinweis noch auf das
spitzenspiel in der wm-quali der
fußballfrauen portugal gegen deutschland
jetzt live zu sehen auf zdf heute.de und
in der zdf- heute
und so den final bei der tischtennis-wm
in houston der hat china alle titel
gewonnen bis auf einen der ging an die
schwedin bei den männern bezwangen
christian carlsson matthias falk
mit 3 zu 1 sätzen das erste mal seit
1991 das wieder ein europäisches doppel
die goldmedaille holt und beim letzten
wm wettbewerb im männer einzel gewann
der chinese van gent mit 14 0 gegen den
schweden trotz höherer gott der zuvor
dem deutschen timo boll im halbfinale
besiegt hatte
ja das war es von mir am anfang habe ich
glaube ich von houston gesprochen das
war aber in innsbruck ist ein bisschen
weit auseinander aber jetzt 14 sitzen
noch auf ich danke jedenfalls so dass so
die queen hat eine echte perle verloren
diese insel in der karibik barbados hat
sich von der britischen monarchie
losgesagt und feiert sich nun als
republik als gast geladen thronfolger
charles er sprach von einer ehre beim
abschied dabei sein zu dürfen auch wenn
ihnen das tropische klima ein wenig
erschöpft
so ein wetter morgen kommt ein sturm wo
genau weiß gleich bad honnefer im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn spricht
christian sievers mit olaf scholz wir
danken für ihr interesse empfehlen
gleich das zdf spezial und sagen tschüss
bis machen
[Musik]
guten abend da kommt ein sturmtief heran
sturmtief daniel bringt viel regen mit
viel wind und erstmal auch mildere
temperaturen
das macht sich schon heute nacht
bemerkbar denn im nordwesten sinken die
werte nicht unter 8 bis 4 grad wird es
sich der elbe in den mittelgebirgen und
in süddeutschland geht's auf plus 3 bis
minus 1 grad runter da reicht also
überall noch für glätte zumal aus den
wolken hier und da auch noch etwas
schneeregen rauskommt sonst fällt
kräftiger regen und der wind nimmt schon
durch zu und sie sehen hier sehr schön
wieder sich hier über der nordsee zu
einem richtigen tief ein klingelt und
dieses tief wird dann eben bis morgen
abend lübeck erreicht haben machen sie
sich morgen auf viel regen gefasst da
viel wind anfänglich ist in mecklenburg
vorpommern auch noch ein bisschen schnee
dabei anders sieht es am alpenrand aus
da haben sie chancen auf etwas
sonnenschein in südwest wind klettern
morgen die temperaturen auf vier grad in
den östlichen mittelgebirgen und bis 10
grad ganz im westen am rhein auch auf
den ostfriesischen inseln in den
nächsten tagen ändert sich das wetter
gleich wieder am donnerstag dreht der
wind auf nord west danach wird es kälter
und am samstag dann schon wieder wilder
nämlich milder und windiger schönen
abend